un mot de Gatel qu'est-ce que vous
inspire ce rapport de vos
collectionnatrices d'abord je voudrais
saluer leur travail parce que c'était un
travail
assez inédit
et rassemblant finalement l'ensemble de
l'effic hippolytique autour de constat
absolument édifiant
sordide qui s'inscrivent aussi dans un
contexte judiciaire particulier
pour moi il y a plusieurs choses il y a
la question il y a la question de la
protection des enfants à travers la
restriction d'accès qui est absolument
indispensable
un chiffre
première image pornographique vu par les
enfants c'est à l'âge de 9 ans 9 ans
compte tenu de l'image qui est véhiculée
des femmes dans ces dans cette
pornographie évidemment ça ne ça ne
laisse personne indemne et il faut tout
faire pour que les lois que nous avons
votées en 2020 et en 2022 puissent enfin
s'appliquer c'est-à-dire l'interdiction
strict de la pornographie pour les
mineurs et puis sur le sur l'aspect
l'aspect de l'image des femmes
véhiculées on est là quand même sur des
questions d'exploitation sexuelle de
traîtres de traite d'être humain
absolument épouvantable et il faut
évidemment renforcer les devoirs et les
obligations des plateformes parce
qu'aujourd'hui ils s'affranchissent en
disant nous ne sommes que des diffuseurs
ça c'est absolument inacceptable
l'industrie l'industrie pornographique
et
gangrené par des pratiques ignobles et
il faut évidemment qu'on agisse vous ça
veut dire que c'est un peu une zone de
non-droit qui faut réglementer et ce
qu'il faut créer dans le code pénal un
nouveau délit d'incitation aux violences
sexuelles telles qu'on les a vu énumérés
dans dans le sujet alors à titre
personnel moi j'y suis favorable et je
suis favorable aussi parce qu'on
revienne sur la question éditeur
diffuseurs des plateformes c'est trop
facile de de faire de l'argent puisqu'on
parle quand même de milliards d'euros
lié à l'industrie pornographique au
niveau mondial souhaitant de jeunes
femmes en exploitant des jeunes femmes
et en disant je ne suis pas au courant
des conditions de tournage moi j'ai une
charte de déontologie si elle est pas si
si elle n'est pas respectée c'est pas
mon problème si c'est mon problème parce
qu'à partir du moment où je suis
diffuseur alors cette question des
plateformes elle n'est pas seulement
pour la question de la pornographie mais
il faut vraiment qu'on avance sur ce
sujet l'Union européenne a beaucoup
avancé sur la sur cette question il faut
désormais qu'on aille plus loin
notamment sur la question de la
pornographie c'est ça c'est un problème
international est-ce que nous en France
on a les moyens de combattre ces grandes
plateformes pornographiques qui sont des
multinationales je pense qu'on a les
moyens
l'interdiction de la diffusion à des
mineurs de moins de 18 ans charge à nous
de la faire respecter il y a des il y a
des il y a des logiciels qui existent il
y a des moi ça ne m'intéresse pas de
savoir comment est-ce que les
plateformes s'y prennent simplement je
ne veux plus que les mineurs puissent
avoir accès à ces images vous imaginez
le traumatisme pour ces pour ses enfants
quand ils sont exposés à ce genre
d'images de 9 ans dès l'âge de 9 ans
moins de 15 ans c'est deux tiers des
enfants qui ont vu des films ou des
extraits de films pornographiques
évidemment ça construit une relation à
l'autre une relation à la femme
notamment qui n'est absolument pas celle
à laquelle la société doit aspirer donc
il faut qu'on agisse et qu'on agisse
fort et vraiment je voudrais saluer le
travail qui a été fait par ces quatre
sénatrices
[Musique]